despite the fed's pause on interest rate
hikes many home buyers around the
country are still feeling the pinch when
it comes to borrowing costs the average
rate for a 30-year fixed mortgage is
nearly seven percent that's more than
double what it was two years ago but in
some places home prices are now
Carter Evans spoke with buyers in
Northern California where homes are
still among the most expensive in the
country
so this is a two million dollar starter
home correct yes don't let the
eye-popping price for this 1300 square
foot home in Silicon Valley fool you so
how quickly will they sell I would
imagine it's going to sell within the
first week or so Wow real estate agent
Joel steber says 2 million is a deal and
he anticipates multiple offers it'll
sell for over asking it will but it's
still not as expensive as it would have
been correct Northern California home
prices jumped during the pandemic but
now the region has seen some of the
steepest price declines in the nation
enticing buyers like Odin Chavez did you
feel like when prices dipped a little
bit like maybe you might be able to get
a deal that's what we were hoping for
but it hasn't happened so they recently
made an offer over asking and we got
outbid by close to a quarter million the
problem is low inventory according to
real estate agent Kelly Dipple there's
more buyers than available homes why are
there so few houses on the market people
that have locked in these low interest
rates are they really going to want to
sell their house and buy something else
for close to seven percent
they're going to hang on and that's
creating a frenzy for what is on the
market
Christine Cole Robinson got into a
bidding war there were 15 other offers
on this house this house this house yeah
so you really went to battle yes we did
Stever says successful buyers in this
market have to be willing to compromise
on what they want and be willing to pay
more for it usually it's a multiple
offer situation they're removing all
their contingencies their loan appraisal
and property inspection contingency
that sounds like during the peak of the
pandemic again it really does yeah it's
happening all over again and experts
suggest a home buying crunch won't clear
until interest rates come back down for
CBS mornings I'm Carter Evans in Silicon
Valley